we have a voicemail number that you can
call anytime
that number is 2192 david p i continue
to hear from folks who are
not as convinced as i am that a split in
the republican party and a trump party
would be good for the left here's a
caller asking about
exactly that issue hey david this is
stewart from wisconsin
so i what just watched your segment um
regarding the republican party and 64
possibly leaving uh for uh trump party
right and i know many say that is a good
thing for the dumb party
because it would you know split up the
votes of the republican party but i
don't know if that's the case i think
that
uh it may be the case that it's good for
the democratic party
however i think that this trump party
may be a problem from the standpoint of
violence
i mean can you okay uh so i think they
said can you imagine take
using one of my my phrases there as i
said earlier today
in the fight between neocon and kewanon
which is essentially what republicans
versus trumpists would be
if q anon gets big and becomes
dominant on the right i completely agree
that there is a very real risk of
increased violence
in the united states as evidenced by the
january sixth riots
that's a different question as as to
what it means politically for the left
in the democratic party i think without
question
uh if the right is fractured listen it's
already borderline
the right already lost the white house
and the senate in 2020
the way that they are currently sort of
assembled so
i think that already the ability of the
republican party
without some modifications to win
national elections is really in question
if you fracture it at all it is good for
the democratic party
if they are actually set up and ready to
take advantage of it there is no
question that there is a whole other set
of considerations and if you see
the q anon wing of the republican party
grow and become further weaponized even
against other republicans that they see
as traitors
it could be extraordinarily dangerous
for this country
and it will keep the hate group watchers
very very busy
for long periods of time to come so i i
don't disagree with the call
i just think the political
considerations are different ones we
have a great bonus show for you today we
will talk about joe biden extending
protections for homeowners
very interesting set of changes that is
being made
we will also talk about a warning that a
january 6th commission to investigate
the trump riots
may be quite difficult politically we'll
talk about why
and the texas mayor has resigned after
calling power outage victims
lazy at least the guys taking personal
responsibility right
all of those stories and more on today's
bonus show
get instant access by becoming a member
at joinpackman.com i'll see you then